today the state's employment agency
deter addressing lawmakers regarding
senate bill 75 which it says will
provide some guidance moving forward
reporter kate houston in our newsroom to
break down what exactly was discussed
during that meeting kate
yes brian during the nearly four hour
long hearing dieter
lawmakers and the public were all able
to have their thoughts heard
on a variety of issues dieter outlined
many different revisions it would like
to make
to ensure that they can handle an
onslaught of unemployment claims in the
future
now some of the discussions centered
around who is excluded from unemployment
assistance
specifically those within education
deters says
federal law does not allow teachers to
receive assistance during summer months
if they have a job to go back to in the
fall this also applies to support staff
such as
bus drivers and food service workers the
teachers union the nevada state
education association
wants an amendment to the bill to allow
9 10 and 11 month support staff
to be eligible for assistance
representatives say
another summer with limited
opportunities due to the pandemic
would mean thousands of nevadans would
go without income
whether we're saying backbone or
lifeblood esps make our schools run
you know from fixing kids cuts and
scrapes to keeping our schools safe they
do it
all we ask that you adopt this amendment
so that they can make a living wage i
think we owe that to them
deters says the discussion of who does
and does not get unemployment is a
policy issue
for lawmakers during the hearing some
were asking about provisions for
pandemic unemployment assistance or pua
pua is a federal program so deter is not
able to change
any rules or regulations back to you